♪♪Music♪♪
[eggs breaking]
[hammer smashing play button]
[drums]
♪♪ drumming ♪♪
[eggs breaking]
GOOOOOSE!!
[hammer smashing play button]
Markiplier says, "Mah boy!"
[eggs breaking]
[Laughing]
GOOSE!!
[Markiplier smashing play button with foot]
[Grunt]
[eggs breaking]
Turkey Tyler goes, "GOBBLE, GOBBLE!"
GOOSE!!
[Markiplier smashing play button]
[eggs breaking]
[fingers snapping]
GOOSE!!
[hammer smashing play button]
Oh. OH! OH GOD!
[eggs breaking and markiplier screaming]
GOOSE!!
[hammer smashing play button]
[eggs breaking]
Woah woah!!
[finger snapping]
GOOSE!!
[Markiplier kicking play button]
[eggs breaking]
[fists punching]
I told you not to do that!
[fingers snapping]
GOOSE!!
Oh my God!
[eggs breaking]
♪♪ drumming ♪♪